talk to me about bitcoin and kind of the
crypto market i know that uh that is now
pretty much entered into the economic
conversation uh because it seems like
there's an entire generation of kids who
you know they might not be so interested
in bonds or stocks or gold and uh and
bitcoin cryptocurrencies is pretty much
the entire piece of their uh their
financial portfolio
yep well i think it's here to stay and
i'm grateful for that um you know just
non-politically i'm i'm sort of amateur
enthusiast about all this stuff i've
been into it for a number of years um i
used to run a program called the teal
fellowship and vitalik butter and of
course he founded ethereum uh was a 2015
teal fellow so we were smart enough at
the time to recognize his talent and and
you know welcome him into the program i
wish i was smart enough to participate
in the ico but i did not do that um but
i think this stuff is super innovative
and and putting a political lens on i
think there's even an argument and i
admit this is just a theory i'm not sure
it'll turn out this way but there's at
least an argument why bitcoin uh
specifically could be really good for
the us dollar you know usually i hear
people in political discourse frame them
as sort of antagonists necessary
adversaries and you can sort of see why
right because
of course central uh
bank digital or central bank currency
like um
like the us dollar is is centralized and
controlled and sort of inherently
inflationary uh
contrast to bitcoin obviously
decentralized no one government can can
control it um non-inflationary or even
deflationary but i actually think that
bitcoin could be the one technological
check on the fed and maybe just the one
check on the fed like i want to get into
the u.s senate and provide a political
check on the fed because i think things
have just gotten out of control
but what if i can't do that right what
if the u.s senate at this point just
can't exercise meaningful political
control over the fed then wouldn't you
like something like bitcoin um this
uncancelable digital you know
decentralized protocol
why wouldn't that actually just make
policymakers more disciplined because if
you can print six trillion dollars well
maybe you get away with that if you're
the world's reserve currency and there's
no other option but now in bitcoin you
have it these investors finally have a
decentralized option uh and so my hope
is as the fed sees now if they just
continue to print money you're going to
get tons of inflation in usd and
investors are going to flock to you know
digital gold um
not a perfect metaphor but a decent one
maybe bitcoin in its very existence will
tell our policy makers hey you got to
put on the brakes here um and actually
shore off our financial system again
maybe an optimistic hope but it is my
hope yeah talk to me a little bit in
terms of when you say the
bitcoin kind of market or investors uh
and their relationship to the us dollar
or how bitcoin could potentially help
the u.s dollar uh how do you think that
could work
well simply by uh stopping inflation
right um i don't think you can print as
much money in a world with bitcoin if
you're a central banker if you're if
you're running the fed i don't think you
can print as much usd as you could
without bitcoin
right um it's it's kind of scary to
imagine a world where the us dollar is
no longer sort of uh automatically the
reserve currency but i think we're
getting there we're getting their
geopolitically um and we're getting
there technologically with bitcoin and
the rise of crypto so yeah i'm not an
investment advisor but i do think uh you
know people should own some part of
their net worth in bitcoin and i think
when more and more people do that and
and right now i think cat's out of the
bag like
you know bitcoin is here to stay um i
think that could exercise a huge
disciplining function on u.s
policymakers and if not then bitcoin's
just gonna you know i think the dollar
will eventually crash and bitcoin or
something like it uh
will be the safe haven hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time